the awful reality of Carabas a tubes
being inserted down his nose to relieve
air and fluid in his abdomen the medical
team is facing multiple challenges every
day and now in Texas a surge in
infections which many believe is the
cost of lifting lockdown early
coronavirus kills you he tells us for
Elias Rubio even survival feels like
death this hospital in Houston has set
up isolation pods with negative air
pressure to seal off the contamination
the number of cases in Texas has nearly
tripled in two weeks and they're
expected to soar again after
Independence Day celebrations with the
doctors frantic about how they cope I
don't have it you will die I mean it's
simple as that there is no more mr. nice
guy
no more please underdog if you go out
this fourth of July to mass gathering we
have the potential of dying yourself or
killing somebody else and I only takes
meeting one infected person to catch it
everybody except one family the family
across the street and he got infected
he's now bitterly critical at the Texas
governor for ending the stay at home
order but our governor
we went along with the president every
health worker has a photograph of
themselves around their neck to help
connect with patients and every movement
between wards requires D robbing and
disposing of the old clothing there's no
shortage of protective equipment here
their rigorous hygiene control is part
of a battle ethos against the virus with
the chief medic determined he won't be
beaten by it
we're fighting two wars what number one
is the Java virus what number two is
stupidity because there are some people
out there just really I don't know how
they're still alive the infections in
Texas have spiked but the mortality
rates much lower and the medics are
trying everything they've devised one
treatment here by mixing steroids
vitamins and anticoagulants and they're
getting results this is the cocktail of
drugs which the doctors at this hospital
have been giving their coronavirus
patients in which they say is
responsible for an astonishing 96
percent success rate it costs just $100
a day and they believe it's going to
turn the corner
in this fight against the deadly virus
they're going to need it to work with
record numbers of infections daily in
Texas and grim warnings to other
countries not to make the same mistakes
as them a lot of people are gonna die
being ignorant and ignorance is never a
defense so they're gonna die so and
they're gonna be made the example for
the rest of the country and Britain
England Africa well if they don't take
this serious they're gonna die and it's
gonna be there but even knowing the
risks is no absolute guarantee Tana
ingre ham was a nurse in this ICU a week
ago but was infected by patient and is
now under the care of her colleagues
it's sad because these these patients
when they come in if you don't hug your
your your family member like right then
you say you're gonna be able to hug him
again you know we don't know and that's
to me that's probably one of the hardest
things the doctors here have opened a
new wing for more coronavirus patients
and the next few weeks are going to be
critical Alex Crawford Sky News in
Houston Texas